At mind with three bullets.
I was thinking that the other day about marriage,
that marriage is essentially Russian roulette with three bullets
because one's going to die first.
50% of marriages end in divorce.
Then there's the Chris rock line.
That's just,
he goes,
that's just the people that had the courage to get out.
He's like,
how many cowards is stay in suffer.
Yeah.
So true.
True Catholic.
Yeah,
and this is coming from a guy who's happily married,
but that's when I,
when I see people who are about to get married,
I go,
Oh,
good Lord.
Yeah.
Well,
you're married.
Yeah.
As I said,
this is coming from guy was happily married.
Yeah.
It works.
Which I'm a Chris Rock.
He's divorced.
No,
I mean,
but me,
I see people get married and I'm like,
Oh yeah.
It's always assumed was that I always tell people like,
yeah,
I'm married a man.
Happy.
I love it.
Don't do it.
Yeah.
Don't do as too risky,
dude.
That's why I got to have you on advice from a dipshit because Amanda will call
through and she'll get like marriage advice.
We have a lot every single month that people call in and say,
hey man,
should I,
should I?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
You can't give people advice because first of all,
there is no fucking way.
I know how you actually are together when you're alone.
I don't know that,
but it's advice from a dip shit,
so I can go by myself and go,
just make sure you're doing this,
this,
and this,
and then you're on your fucking own.
You know?
They're not quote me.
You should have Dr Laura on your show ever be mean to my God.
Be Amazing.